though and I'm great for kids
I'm fantastic
really yeah yeah that shouldn't affect
her yeah but it but it affects how you
are in a relationship because you bring
that damage into future relationships I
think the damage that you've got is your
responsibility to to go away and heal
from it I I agree with you but what's
better a girl that's not damaged or a
girl that is
I I understand I do understand what
you're saying but say if you got married
and then a guy damaged you within that
marriage you even though you've only
slept with that person you would still
be damaged
right but they're prop like there are
problems not other people's problems and
the issue is like you're bringing other
people's problems into your relationship
which is then why you would need to go
away and work on yourself no which is
why you should have less Partners before
you get married which is why we should
try to remain as pure as possible before
we get married like why would you want
more experience before getting married I
do I do why would you like what value
does that bring to a husband I've just
I've just thought um you know like that
time when you're little or you have to
kiss a lot of frogs before you get your
your prince so that's a bad saying I
think that's experience that's what
we've grown up on though so that's when
I'm saying as girls we I I personally
wasn't told by anyone oh if you sleep
with a lot of people your value as a
woman's gonna go down if if I was told
that you think do you think that final
figure has an important role in that
to be fair yeah actually maybe but then
my my mom didn't say that either well we
know the sun some level because the
first thing you do and you don't like a
girl is you call her a [__] maybe not
you personally but you know women do
that so I think we know on some level
that Purity is important to me I don't
think when you're 16 17 though I don't
think you think about that at all at all
do you guys have no guidance from your
parents no my mom didn't talk about sex
with me at all not even did you lose
your dad in your life yeah yeah both
parents and they never they never spoke
to you about sex ever never maybe they
should I I do think they should have
definitely because I'm not saying that
um I would go back and change things
because I I do feel like even through
breakups and bad breakups you out from
the other side and the end of the tunnel
you become a better person anyway
because you've I feel like I think I
think you become a worse person as as a
human expect being a human on the planet
having a human experience they say that
to have a full experience as a human you
have to go through ups and downs that's
not just in relationships that's
experiences in general yeah so you
should go through them with your husband
but I would rather go through I'm not on
about just relationships but as an
experience I would rather go through
that on my own so then when I'm with my
husband I've already learned all of that
yeah no no
but why would you not want to know it
but listen
as an individual on the planet as an
individual going for your own life
surely you would want to know everything
about yourself everything that triggers
you everything that you know you've
learned from and all of that and then
have a husband that you can build even
more you're not going to go wrong
because why would you want to be in a
marriage not knowing yourself yeah 100
like why would you why would you want to
do that yeah but from the dawn of time
like from the ancient times girls have
gotten married at a young age I don't
agree with that they don't need that
they didn't get married at first girls
got married at 16 17 18. that was just
something that just happened like things
from from the whole of like from ages
ago it's a new thing to get married but
maybe sometimes they didn't actually
have a choice yeah but it's not that but
it was like it was a tradition
to get married
because we look at what works and like
let's let's look at the outcomes are
women happier waiting to get married
right the average age of first marriage
is 31 100 years ago it was around 20 21
something like that and women are more
on antidepressants we're more depressed
than ever we're on what Tinder where
average body count is like what eight
ten and like I I genuinely think it's
probably higher than that if we're being
honest you know
um if we're not happy women are not
happy waiting to get married and then
getting married I think happiness is a
choice though I think I do think
happiness is a choice but I do think we
can look at outcomes yeah I I completely
understand where you're coming from but
again I think it's so important to take
the time away and focus on yourself
Austin what do you think the difference
between happiness for a woman is and
happiness for a month
what do you think freedom
be more break it down let's see what's
the difference between the happiness for
a man and the happiness for a woman
what's the difference
I think when you're both happy I think
that's when you can be completely happy
yeah
for a woman yeah what makes a woman
happy like happy like Papa happy and
fulfilled and what makes a man happy and
fulfilled I think it's personal
preference yeah I think it's different
everyone is different but to generalize
it I think for a man it's having a woman
who
this is gonna sound so politically wrong
but I know that guys can cheat and be
and still love someone and and then if
they were to then go back to that woman
and that woman takes them back it would
give him status because look how much my
woman loves me she's done
anyone that's a [__] boy why would he
telling anyone what you mean but he
doesn't have to that's not stupid I
think she's saying it's a thought
process that's not status like posting
about uh his girl taking them back to
Sunday but some guys do do that I've
heard I've seen a podcast with them
having this whole conversation I'm not
saying just specifically that that's not
what makes a woman what makes a woman
happy
I think being cared for provided for
looked after and respected recognized
okay that's that's very good but also
you don't need permanent yes you do yes
but not all there's nothing you wouldn't
the only reason like we have a we have a
society where women are like delusional
enough to think that we can't live
without men no offense uh because like
what what do you do when your car breaks
down you go to a man what do you do who
built this building a man
no not really all the industries that
run Society are primarily I mean it's
not that they can't we don't and we
won't we refuse to do hard jobs all the
hardest jobs
no not really if even if you look at
them and I've talked to like I do
interviews sometimes with people in
these industries typically the women are
the ones waving the flags on the
construction sites or they're like in
the middle management like most women
are out there building and if they're
doing it come on they're bad at it let's
just call spade a spade like you're not
you're not just good at like doing
manual labor as a man you can't be we're
not as strong as them and so yeah we're
not as strong as men if there's if
there's a blackout tomorrow right if
there's a blackout tomorrow you would
run to a guy because you need a guy to
protect you they did a study right or
not a study a TV show where um they put
men and women on an island it said
survive go the women had to be rescued
in two days and in like five days the
men were filtering water hunting food
like they had a whole system that's just
how would life differently built like
right but that's what I'm saying like
women like we're in a society where we
have like propped up women to think that
we can live without men when everything
we do depends on men like then they need
us women to be here no not really
because like okay let's let's say
reproduction's equal right we can't say
because we need we need their sperm they
need our so we can't we can't take more
credit for reproduction like that's
equal but when it comes to a baby though
whereas a woman can't okay but what okay
if they build artificial wombs tomorrow
then what
there's no laws stopping us from doing
any of these industries if you want you
can go be a plumber you could go be a
mechanic but I'm sure none of you want
to and I sure as hell don't right you
don't want to I don't want to either and
and it's interesting because I talked to
this like historian the other day and he
said there have just been such
ramifications from women entering the
workforce in the 20s
because like that's like the that as
soon as women entered the workforce in
the 20s that's when the number of
children went down and that's when like
um that's when you couldn't survive on
two incomes so there's been a lot of
ramification I'm not saying good or bad
but from women entering the workforce
but they they say they don't eat men
right but hypothetically
you see how big that muscle is about the
the security guard for the show right if
he was to try to violate you
they say me and you were together
Courtney
and we were walking down the street hey
if he was trying to violate you he would
have to kill me to get you
you don't see value in that because
because when he means it enough because
what I'm saying the point that you guys
are we've conquered the world to the
point where you guys are so protected to
the point that you guys don't even see
valuable and simple security you guys
are entitled to security
you understand that I don't have to
protect you if if someone as big as him
was to try to violate you he would have
to kill me I don't have to do that for
you
to the point to say that you don't need
men you do need Men You're so secure
because the fact that we've conquered
the world I think we have gave you that
security but you're not entitled to it
you're not entitled to it all right so
if we're walking together and he says
something what are you gonna do yeah but
it wasn't aimed I'm not saying that
though no but she's talking about
needing men you do need men yeah because
you're not entitled to security you can
walk down the street right now and
somebody attack you right but if you had
a man with you that man would be willing
to die for you then and they're on the
spot yeah you with me I I'm a I'm a dive
you gotta kill me
so you mean men don't let this society
that we've conquered and built is so
secure for you forget that because a man
could see a a pervert a pedophile
whatever because see you walking oh
she's pretty she's got a skirt on
let me find an opportunity he's going to
follow bro why is that so special bro is
that not a normal that's normal for God
to protect the girl why are you Dylan on
it because they don't value them
not you particularly but we're talking
about modern women not valuing men and
one the thing that men one of the men
that one of the things that men brings
to the table more than anything is
protection okay bro that's not important
it's new movies
out there that won't do nothing there
are men out there there are men out
there that when men do something to
their women they will not do anything
they are cowards and they want to do
anything do not tell me that it's not
valuable for a man to stand for women
because 99
it's not normal
yes
you would yes you would yes you would I
would anyone else would only a little
geek whatever and there's a lot of
cowards out there that's what I'm saying
that's what I'm saying
it would be surprising I think exactly I
think it's normal for a guy
I've seen plenty of dudes lay down and
do nothing where you from America [__]
America I don't care about my computer
you say we just said whatever cool and
that's cool I've not seen a guy that's
stepped down from like protecting his
goal I've seen that this is that 13
times I've seen it I've not seen it like
who's gonna run who's obviously gonna
run away from his girl I've seen it I've
seen dudes like grab a girl's ass and
the dude really does nothing because
exactly I've seen that's right if you
love him as well
I'm kind of torn I've seen both you know
what I mean
yeah you're saying that it happens but
it's not it's not common bro but it
happens
exactly but it's not about people
because everyone does it it's normal bro
it's normal for God to protect the woman
easier but he doesn't have to do it the
point is the value they have to see
value in it of course they have to do it
bro it's normal no but it's if you okay
it's like if you're single right there's
some value in having a boyfriend and
that can protect you so if someone
breaks into your apartment at night and
he's there he can protect you you know
that's what I think I think it might be
normal but that's what he's trying to
say that women don't value that yeah but
like women don't I'm saying that it's
not about I'm not I'm not saying that
it's not normal that a man shouldn't do
it a man being a man should do it what
I'm saying is that generally modern
women today don't value the simple thing
of a protection which is the most
valuable thing a man can do it's not the
most valuable thing it is the most
valuable thing to lay your life on a
line for a woman is the most valuable
thing you can do it's the most valuable
thing to do this if I love a woman I
will die for there on the spot this is
my life this is all I have because that
is
average you might be saying it's normal
on average but you'd be surprised about
how many men don't do it that's his yeah
he's he's agreeing with you
to you it is normal to me it is normal a
guy should do that but you'd be
surprised about how many men and that's
his problem that's his point he's
arguing the fact that bro we're on the
same level but it's like just a little
bit you'll say
valuable it's so valuable it's normal
it's not valuable it's normal no it is
value it's not it's normal I still I
listen like I said I don't know where
you're from bro but where I'm from a lot
of [__] happens
bro I've seen a lot of [__] happen lay
down like [__] don't really happen and
dudes do nothing
bro like really it'll happen America is
very different from the UK and I I
personally I haven't been there but even
just on TV you can see how Savage but
it's in general though just from you can
see
emotion how far
you've seen it I've done I've done stood
up for my dudes a girlfriend when he
wouldn't stand up for us bro
it's not normal
it should be normal and a man should do
that what I'm saying is that there are
men out there that will not do that and
what I'm saying is that most men women
don't that most modern women don't value
the Simplicity of security you're not
interested they're not gonna bully they
expect it it's normal for them that's
his point so you're just not
understanding it's like he just wants to
argue no I don't think so I think you
guys are just misunderstanding each
other like yeah I think that's his point
though like that women don't value it
and it's like like his point is that
women don't respect average men nowaday
even when they're average women
like I think I think that's I think let
me tell you something I think protecting
a girl is normal average standards it's
just normal you can't it's not something
that you value it's normal average yeah
I also think a man doesn't value a woman
enough
huh
do you not hear what I said what'd you
say I said I don't think a man values a
woman enough why is that why do you
think that
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible